hey guys it's Justine and I'm here with
ROH and today I have a surprise for her
your techie but like whoa
Justine teaches me how to use everything
she just taught me how to do stuff on my
phone just now right before we start me
show you the control center how you can
add your screen recording to it I was
like you go wow that is gonna be very
important because today I brought with
me two phones
they have the beta version of iowa's 13
so a lot of you guys watching you may be
wondering oh as iOS 13 out can I get it
you can if you have a developer's
account so this is currently running
well iowa's 13 super exciting because it
has some new emoji features huh I've
never made a MIMO g4
you've never made will address me I
don't even know what I'm doing something
new and iOS are team that I'm gonna show
you this is dark mode and this is normal
light mode this is what your phone
normally looks like and now they have
this mode I think it's cool cuz during
the daytime I do like it on light and
enough that you mean sometimes I'll even
change my wallpaper to be darker yeah so
this is perfect now my light down I'll
turn my whole wallpaper no you can do
that so I can't believe that you're
gonna make your first emoji okay you
ready I guess
I'm gonna give you this one like we
should make me mode use of each other so
this is showing you like a little demo
of like it's really really cool okay so
here we go okay I'm gonna do this to you
freckles no not really you don't have
any friends do you have apples I do but
I hide them okay they're hidden skin
tones
that's to all of that's 210 okay what
else for that do you have any
distinctive moles I don't so if you
notice this is picking up beating room I
do but they don't have the beauty mark
where I have one do you have one
[Music]
well if you notice this is picking up
your voice and face it's following me
stick your tongue out so let me get that
blinder doing you do a slight side part
I do a middle first middle yeah okay
they have a strong middle they do look
at me seriously eyebrow yes okay very
nice caterpillars oh my gosh look it
look like Daenerys oh my gosh I love it
you have pretty big eyes I would say
like oh yeah definitely here got me this
okay the other big my eye colors these
branches a little bit red in the Sun
they give really honey colored in the
Sun they're kind of creepy like that
yeah yeah your eyes are green he's
depending on what you're wearing you
look more blue
yeah I just don't know today green
you're still on that you know it's
coming long before head do they have one
with a thing we've got some new
customizations but they don't have I
think they don't have this big forehead
feature
leaving me out what do you do a big
forehead no you have a small forehead
very small very nice okay that's not I
have a huge forehead I got this
yeah but you're like a foot taller than
me I'm like four foot nothing four foot
ten I mean you gotta smell those I'll
give you a small do have a small do you
want to know is piercing you can add
piercings yes God knows you're like mmm
like it like I'm giving you a nice
little diamond nose-ring I think that
looks good if you don't know what shape
your head is and I can't tell the
difference these are square that's not
you like not only point even like it's
got a little definition
cuz it's it's there I'm very I'm
masculine chin donate it would be
something that I would define your chin
as is it hello so I think maybe my face
shape may be a little weird for you let
me
lips look like um either's are more
round little Yama's point yes mine but
still a little pointy in the middle a
little bit
do you have braces fangs gold teeth you
don't you have nice talent just great
teeth so many have little ears oh you
didn't earrings I'm gonna make them
diamond to match your nose piercing does
ro want some facial hair it's hard to do
your lips right now someone do that okay
gosh I look great with a beard I know
this is what it would look like if I had
a moustache and I look like little Papa
pizza
I see look good man that was dot our
fathers daughter
yours you can't even see him who who
cares you have little ears so you're not
wearing glasses too like we could put
iPods onions air puffs air plug yeah we
could put air pods on you don't get me
wrong I would definitely wear iPods on
my ears we have to give you glasses do
you do huh I am making you the cutest
hat oh my gosh I can give you a little
headpiece a turban I could give you if
you give me AI hat you're an adventurer
I love it okay now I'm having done so
now you know how like you send emojis
yes well this automatically makes emojis
looks if you peace love you yes so
instead of saying like a normal emoji
you can send like the hard eyes with
your emoji are you writing so I loved it
my phone means aren't delivered because
this is just like a beta phone so
modding is actually linked up oh my gosh
look at this like Facebook now yeah cute
I can't believe you've ever used emojis
before no but I am using shop it's me oh
wow I really I can't not sure about the
nose piercing bug to be like the time
you can send them it's so great because
it'll just send that little video it's
so cute I want to love me like a million
video I'm gonna net one money you now
little wink I oh my gosh mine's really
cute here's this adorable and I think
because it would match like your gaming
controllers and stuff I love this face
wait that looks just like me oh my god
that looks like you didn't Audi that's
paddy 1500 having a girl 8 give it eight
eight tentacles hi
so I've got a hat that's not glasses on
me
that looks like you that is you as a
credit cute I don't
these are Newkirk I know you look so
cute so do you you look like Legally
Blonde and I I'm a vampire like I'm kind
of like preppy Punk I love my vampire
things to make piercings and I'm like
preppy punk and you're like Legally
Blonde okay I feel says we're all know
we're all in trouble because now rows
only going this is an emo geez oh I
can't wait so if you'll be able to get
that and September when the new iPhone
comes out we're with the latest iowa's
it comes out which is usually a week
flow the new iPhone and the new iPhones
are usually in September that's new
iPhone 6s whoa yeah
it's like Kashi shows you know the
seasons of I I don't have a hygiene yeah
well this was so much fun thank you so
much this is great if you guys enjoyed
this and if you would like to see maybe
like I mean orgy cartoon with us oh let
us know because that would be so fun
oh my god I love it I have so many ideas
right now I was not gonna be so cool to
be a guest star and something well I'm
so ready this I love it
should we almost anybody talk show yes I
would love that as well also Justine I'm
like I'm tripping because I just learned
something new you just you like taught
me like like at school like I didn't
know any of this
that's why my name is blood alright this
is so fun late to the party but I'm
enjoying this party well make sure you
guys go check out ROS channel we have
done so many amazing videos together
I'll actually put a playlist all of the
videos that we've done together some on
mine someone hers we also did a video on
her channel there's up now so make sure
you guys go check that out I'll put a
link in description go subscribe
mostly hi hit all of our buses multiple
please ring our bells there's a new
algorithm it's new and doing its things
it was no one is nothing we love you and
this is so fun send us your meme oh geez
tweet us one and say hi and you're Nev
og voice and face I love all these like
different combos and creations I want to
see what you made I love it you could be
really creative in here you can wall see
you guys later
[Music]